c'est un colloque sur le campus de
schoelcher un colloque pas comme les
autres dans cet amphithéâtre des
professeurs des chercheurs et des
musiciens c'est une réflexion sur le
zouk et parmi ses musiciens pierre
edouard décimus
un nom qui ne dira rien aux jeunes
générations mais c'est lui qui a créé le
groupe kassav à l'époque
jocelyne beroard était sa choriste c'est
aussi pierre edouard decimus qui a donné
au groupe le nom de kassav
il en a fait expérimenter une formule
scientifique japonaise une histoire que
l'on découvre dans l'alu dans l'histoire
de goldorak que goldorak avait tout
inventé par un ordinateur japonais de
laquelle on avait deux mis les
ingrédients qui pouvait faire un beau
succès les lettres j'ai d'autres
qualités certaines lettres pouvait
prédire le succès qu'a savons pas quel
nom on a obtenu kazan parce que cet
article sur goldorak disait qu'il
fallait une histoire pathétique et cette
histoire pathétique j'en ai trouvé parce
que quand j'étais petit ma voisine
lamazou bébés par an la cassave et je
suis allé jouer dans le lait de manioc
et pète on dit maxime une page où adam
saison poison et pour lui cette énergie
tellurique qui apportait kassav a
commencé à circuler
grâce à la diaspora installée dans
l'hexagone entre 1975 et 1990 et ils ont
joué un rôle capital dans
chaque devenu cassaber saljic
autre précision l'association zouk et
kassav le mot zouk existe en martinique
avec le groupe kassav un zouk c'était
une surprise party mais comment les deux
noms se sont ils associés à musique de
kassab étant devenue la musique
majoritairement jouer dans les autres
donc de la musique de zhouqu
exactement comme la musique deux
discothèques est devenu le disco le zouk
de la musique de kassav est devenu zouk
et en fait c'est le morceau zouk la sé
sèl médikaman nou ni qui signe qui
consacre le nom à kassav lanvin qui
donne véritablement à 7 musical nozuka
et quoi de mieux que les acteurs d'un
sujet d'étude pour en parler dans une
université
l'egypte a jamais été présenti haut
niveau au niveau scientifique
justement c'est l'occasion de
d'éclaircies ou de montres et de
justement deux bons trios au monde
universitaire que le zouk
ces parties du génie culturel de nos
peuples et que nous pouvons bien
évidemment l'ériger en objet d'étude
il y a beaucoup de questions autour du
zouk vient il simplement du ti bwa
martiniquais et dubroca guadeloupéens
oui affirment ses créateurs le zouk
serait donc bel et bien né en guadeloupe
et en martinique
c'est en tout cas l'histoire que
retiennent les chercheurs et professeurs
d'université